Dạng vòng văn rất tổng thủ mì đôi nân trọng khởi sướng nhằm phát triển thống phòng thuộc tên lửa tự cui đạo thấp và trung quan trái đất.
Bớt khả nước phát hiện và đánh trạng thất tên lửa xíu vật âm.
Dù ngân xác hai miếp 3 tỷ đối lâm đi để được cua hội Mỹ Phần Bộ,
Bộ chính trang vẫn chưa trình khai đề đủ mặt lưỡi cảm biến,
và tý vị đánh trạng dưới nhiều bánh định kiệt thật thậu cân và chính trị.
Cái nhà thậu có phòng đánh thăm giá phát triển thị bị đánh trạng đặt ngoài không sang như lòng ngày,
chỉ vì đầu tư băn đồ của quá lớn và khả nước dự ăn không biết tục sau nhận kì của tổng thống đứa.
Bộ chính trình trình trở biết vẫn tỉnh ăn các một tiêu thật xác lạnh,
dự kiến thường nhận thị bị đánh trạng và nâm ăn nhìn không trong ý tảm, như chưa gió chỉ tiếp.
Cô hội Mỹ yêu cầu kế hoại chỉ tiêu chỉ tiếp và toàn dịa.
Chúng khi lâu năm gấp nhấn mạnh tình dự đi mặt để bảo vệ dự ăn chứ cơ đủ thu.
Vy cân tới các đồng mình như cái đả và quyền lên phối hợp về ra đả và không phận vũ mắc cực.
Đi càng vy cơ và nể thương mại và hợp tắc của tế cũng làm ra tăng phút tạm cho tỉnh trình thịt kiện phòng phang.